citizens of the reject nation
that's correct you hear that that is me
being sworn in allowed to say such a
virtuous thing to welcome you in hello
you lovelies the x-men are coming and
based off the direction that marvel has
been going and based on the comic runs
they've been utilizing i've got an idea
of the shape the team is going to take
and i've got casting for each of two
different versions that's right this
video is gonna be a little different i'm
gonna cast double and we'll get to that
in just a second but before please do
leave a like youtube likes when we do
that please hit that subscription hit
the bell so you know when more videos
are coming and please leave a comment
below because i've got more than just
these x-men to cast if you want to see
me extend my casting to the greater
x-men universe i've got some more ideas
but we'll get to that in another video
follow me on tick-tock if you want to
see more of my fan casting more comic
ideas more all sorts of nerdy stuff
let's get into it my x-men
so the reason this casting video is
gonna be a little different is i think
they can go two ways in the mcu
especially with the events of miss
marvel they might have a younger cast
maybe people in their 20s aging into the
x-men like we had in the original movies
or they could have an older cast of the
x-men we know and love teaching future
waves of students coming in a la x
factor so i'm gonna cast a 20's era
x-men as well as a mid-30s era
experience you're gonna get two cast for
the price of one first let's kick off
with professor x now there's been a lot
of talk of giancarlo esposito especially
this last week and i think that's a
great call because he is very ominous
while being loving there's something
very paternal about him which is
important for chuck but also there's an
an ominous overtone of potential
duplicity and i think that's really
important to go from the leader of the
x-men the one that gathers the x-men to
eventually becoming apocalypse the fact
that he's friends with magneto we need a
character to seem loving and nurturing
but also like he has a dark side so i
don't necessarily think it's going to be
giancarlo esposito but i think it'd be a
good choice if they go that way my pick
for the older version of the character
would be either ed harris or ralph
fiennes we're going to bring up ralph
finds again in a little bit so let's
lean ed harris on this one ed harris has
been known to carry that i can be
trusted but only so far i'm a very regal
figure i've got a lot of authority but
you could see him going a darker way now
if they go a little bit younger i would
love to see someone that is in the mcu
already but only very briefly sterling k
brown deserves to be a leading man in
the mcu sterling k brown can play both
very reserved controlled calculated but
also very emotional outbursts of rage
outbursts of sheer empathy and and
everything you need in xavier is in that
man i would personally love and i know
he's in black panther i know i know he's
involved but i want to see him get a
leading man role i want sterling k brown
for my professor x now we've brought up
our xavier we gotta bring up our magneto
i do think that even though we've seen a
lot of these two characters on screen
you don't have the x-men without magneto
i would personally have the first film
be based on the sentinels be based on
government oversight be based on the
department of damage control-esque
things but you need your big bad and you
need to build to the brotherhood of evil
mutants you need to build all those
things that are foundational so you need
magneto now i if they go older with an
older magneto really want michael
wincott i don't know if you guys know
that name but you might know him from
the crow you might know him from the
recently released nope this man's
presence is incredible he is an older
actor but every time he's on screen
you're so captivated you're so
interested and his voice if he doesn't
play doom he should play magneto there's
so much history behind this man there's
so much intrigue behind every one of his
weathered lines and i could see him be
just as interesting to be followed as a
leader as someone that you'd be
terrified of and that's very important
for the character magneto if you go
younger this is where we're bringing in
ralph finds i mentioned him for xavier
which i do think is that line of 70 good
thirty percent concerning i wanna see
ralph finds in the in bruges sense i'd
love to see him in the more arrogant but
with purpose like i feel like magneto is
arrogant but that's because he knows
he's the [ __ ] and i think that's ralph
finds the man has bravado in his evil
the man has confidence a lot like
michael fassbender does and i'd really
love to see that version of ralph finds
brought into the mcu he's my magneto now
here's where the age starts to make a
difference those actors are well
established those characters well
established but when you bring in
cyclops you need to make sure they
finally get cyclops right i love james
marston they didn't give james marsden a
lot of the script a lot of the action a
lot of the things you need for cyclops
and he didn't have the ability to emote
a lot because he's got a mask on you
need a very strong actor here if they go
older if they go with a more
professorial someone leading as an
already established x-men i love justin
hartley if you haven't seen this as us
he is absolutely incredible in that show
he has a lot of leadership ability he
has a lot of charisma he has a lot of
ability to do a lot with a very little
amount the man can do a lot with his
face and that's important when it's half
covered and he's got that stoic rigid
every man but want to follow him into
the trenches
ness that is very necessary now that is
someone if the x-men have been
established if they're starting with
young x-men that we're gonna follow
through dylan o'brien man maze runners
showed this guy can lead a franchise
major undershowed this guy is someone
you want to follow into battle maze
runner showed this guy is so charismatic
that he gets people to basically do what
needs to be done in very tricky
situations and you want someone that
jean grey can fall in love with over
wolverine harry bob charm incarnate you
need someone like dylan o'brien and i
think the way to do that is you cast the
leading man dylan o'brien's made to be
cyclops get it right he's a leader him
in storm they gotta lead the x-men they
gotta be great speaking of leaders of
the x-men and in the comic runs i enjoy
in the 90s the jim lee era of x-men
we're going to talk about in the comic
polls later there were two teams there
was the gold team and the blue team and
depending on how the movies go i could
see them splitting the giant team of
x-men into two different factions that
might actually happen and i would love
to see storm be the leader of the x-men
as she is in the comics and you want
someone that's going to be right there
alongside cyclops or boston cyclops
around you need that powerhouse that i
think dewanda weiss is if they have an
older storm i think dewanda weiss she
was just in the newest jurassic world to
me she stole a lot of the scenes she was
in she has a presence about her i would
personally start with a storm solo movie
maybe even casting my young actress as
the flashbacks show her growing up in
africa show her being worshipped as a
god show her claustrophobia show her
having to be a thief to make do and show
her evolving into the goddess of thunder
that she is this is the most cinematic
character in the x-men she's literally a
roland emerick movie come to life she
controls the weather this character
deserves a full film or at least the
leader of the movie dwondaweis can carry
that very very strong weight on her
shoulders and if they go younger i would
say alexis louder if you haven't seen
cop shop stole every scene cop shop is
an actor dream movie you've got gerard
butler and frank grillo acting their
eyeballs out at each other in a
contained environment and alexis louder
debuted effectively in that film and
stole every scene she was in she looks
awesome with a bald head i want to see
with a white mohawk i want to see storm
done in a way that you want to not only
have her lead the x-men but you want to
follow her into the world of black
panther you want to follow her into
wherever they bring that character next
and you need either one of these
actresses to do it dwanda weiss alexis
louder i want to see them in that white
awesome flowing road so what is the
x-men without jean grey now don't you
give me that phoenix sag at first you
earned the phoenix saga that's movie
nine you get there after three trilogies
you don't phoenix me again but on the
way to that you need to make sure this
is a character that you want to buy the
love story of i want to see scott and
gene actually get to love each other
give me some notebook x-men action chris
claremont one of the most iconic ever
writers of the x-men love the soap opera
elements of the x-men we need more of
that we need to believe these characters
before we put them in peril i want to
love jean grey if we go with an older
actress someone in their 30s i want rose
leslie i loved her in game of thrones i
loved every moment we got with her i
love her presence in interviews she's
someone that i want to know more about
and that's important for jean you're in
her head you're sharing a lot of time
with her you have empathy for her as she
gets destructive as things fall apart in
her life and she's so over powerful you
need to have that connection i think
rose leslie definitely has that if they
go younger for growing up with jean grey
i would say either sophia lillis who we
just had in the it movies who is
absolutely captivating you care about
her and peril already we've already seen
that and you care about her in the very
boys world dynamic the x-men it's a lot
of dudes it's called the x-men you want
to make sure there's someone that you're
like wait what does she want like what
does she need in this scenario and i
think she'd be absolutely incredible and
then my other younger cast members jane
levy from shameless she is so
interesting and she's so able to hold
her own amongst a family of heathens
like everyone in shameless is so much
but every time she's on screen you want
to know more about her and that's very
important for jean grey those are my
three schnitz let's talk about wolverine
this is the one everyone's curious about
this is the one i think they should wait
for to be honest i included wolverine
because he's wolverine but i don't want
this to become wolverine the x-men i
think that was what happened to the
detriment of the brian singer films is
it became the wolverine show and his
buddies that's not what the x-men is i
would personally introduce wolverine the
tv show check out the video i made about
that it's on this very channel it's the
first video we ever made of koi's
comments corner follow that journey but
if we are getting wolverine in this
movie i would like if he's older edgar
ramirez edgar ramirez has the
physicality he seems like a guy that
would say bub i see him cigar chomping i
see him as this hairy mutant that's very
feral if they can't get tom hardy
because he's venom i think edgar ramirez
has all of that energy and he seems like
a guy who's seen stream [ __ ] and he can
also do his own stunts which i really
respect if they go younger this is the
most tried and true answer but there's a
reason for it he's short he's stocky he
can act his eyeballs out he's buddies
with hugh jackman he can get the notes
from him i think taran edgerton should
absolutely play the younger wolverine
what's tricky is is i see taran edgerton
maybe aging in the next five years 10
years because he's like 30. that might
be a tricky thing for wolverine so age
him up now that way as he grows into the
older terran edgerton we have an
established wolverine but i think taran
edgerton could absolutely slay it beast
is a founding member of the x-men and a
very hard character to get right i think
nick holt absolutely slayed it i think
the voice of kelsey grammer totally
worked but i want to see a beast that's
actually part of the team that feels
like he's getting to do all the things
that keep the team together i always
felt like beast was the heart of the
x-men that also was incredibly genius
and had a crush on jean grey again soap
opera not only is there the love
triangle with wolverine and gene but i
always felt like there was a bit of
beast that loved her maybe that's just
the ultimate x-men talking either way i
want someone fully invested in this
character for the long game and there's
an actor that i don't think gets enough
love in any medium as a director as an
actor anywhere joel edgerton is such a
force of nature him and warrior him in
the gift which he also directed him and
everything you're always wanting to know
more him in star wars you want to know
more about the uncle that's raising luke
than you i ever expected to he's able to
do so much with so little and i think
that beast needs to be able to act his
eyeballs out because he's covered in
makeup he needs to be able to do a lot
with a little i think his voice is great
i think his stocky build is great i
think he's got the physicality and the
warmth which is very important if they
go younger there's this guy that looks
so much like a young joel edgerton that
i hadn't seen anything of except for the
transformers movies till i saw a couple
of his indies and i was like this guy
that's why he keeps getting cast jack
rainer is incredible when he's not in a
giant tent pole and i think i'd love to
see him in a giant temple getting to
show the indie range that he has so jack
rainer or joel edgerton are my beast i
think nightcrawler should be in from the
very beginning i love allen cummings for
trailing x2 but i want to see
nightcrawler from the all-new x-men i
want to see him jump right in from giant
seismic number one and i think he needs
to be handsome and swashbuckling and
blue and furry and i want dev patel dev
patel has this confidence this
intelligence this very interesting
almost uh shakespearean movement about
him i know that's a weird thing to say
but the way he moves is very in a space
and if you're bamfing around your body
presence is really important and i think
dave patel especially after the green
knight showed me that i want that in
this swashbuckling bamfer and i think
dev patel could do a really great older
nightcrawler if they go younger i want
mr heartthrob himself i think he'd look
good in blue furry makeup i think he'd
be a great draw for audiences and i
think he's got an elfish handsomeness i
want timothy chalamet as the young
nightcrawler and i think he'd absolutely
crush
timothy timmy clementine to be great
dude think about him and doon he comes
in he's got like the the red little
harness on he's banffing around he's got
a sword got tail another founding x-men
that is a very important character to
the team because he's the levity he's
both the levity in comedic moments for
just throwing out one-liners but also
the levity when things get really dark
that he's able to be the warmth
ironically because he's iceman iceman
has been recently revealed to be an
omega level mutant he's one of the most
powerful mutants and he can literally do
what magneto does with magnets but with
all moisture in the air this guy is very
powerful but he's got this comedic
sensibility that it's really important
the character that i think john cho has
john cho a lot of people know from like
harold and kumar and things but if
you've looked at his more recent work in
things like cowboy bebop or especially
searching this guy is so
so talented while also being comedic and
i think that is so essential for iceman
i want to see the iceman from the comics
and i think if they get an older actor
again someone in their 30s that's john
cho they go younger i want someone that
is pure bombast i want someone that is
eccentric i want someone that makes me
go like what is this guy doing a chaos
element someone that would be the team
is going through all this stuff but one
guy's keeping us like okay the world
hates and fears them but this guy's
fascinating robert sheen i want robert
sheehan from umbrella academy icing up
and being bobby drake and being all
sorts of weird these are very two
different casting but i think that's an
example of when the actor ages and the
character ages it changes their dynamics
so jon cho or robert sheen and now for
my penultimate pick i do think this
character will be much more utilized in
these rounds of films kitty pride
everyone kitty pride i think in the
comics right now they've used kitty
pride as a leader quite a few times i
think we've seen that her power set is
very dynamic and can be very useful and
i especially love her current run of the
marauders books where she's literally a
pirate rescuing mutants that can't make
it through krakowa's gates that's
another whole longer conversation but
kitty pride i would love to get her time
in the sun if they go with an older
actress i would say alicia vikander i
think she has shown that she can lead
she's charismatic she deserves a
franchise to be honest she's been in all
these incredible indies and tomb raider
didn't work out she's available i think
she'd be a very interesting leader of
either the main x-men or a subsective
x-men as this world expands if they go
younger i think caitlyn dever is so
charismatic and again another natural
leader and kitty pride's a character
that has a youthfulness to her even as
she ages and i'd love to see the
wolverine kitty pride dynamic like you
have in days or future past and other
things so caitlyn dever of book smart i
think has all those attributes if they
lean younger for k prime all right and
for my last poll he only briefly
appeared in an x-men movie in the worst
of the x-men movies in my opinion x-men
3 and he's a founding member of the
x-men one of my favorite actors playing
ben foster could not do that character
justice they didn't give him the writing
i want this character written well i
want warren worthington iii to age into
the archangel that we kind of got an
apocalypse i want this character to be
the rich playboy that has had everything
he's ever wanted and then literally grew
angel wings and then the world fell
apart around him but he's still got that
billionaire status you need someone that
feels
almost
capitalistically regal in a negative and
positive way you want someone that feels
like they could be a billionaire but
also has the empathy of someone that is
literally an angel but understands
helping people i love michael ely and
he's got a presence about a man he's got
this this stunning visage while also
having the acting chops to play this
heart of the character and if they go
with an older actor i think michael
ealey would be great if they go younger
i think diego banetta has not had a lot
of opportunity to show his range i think
he's a very talented actor with those
flowing locks and everything else he's
got an angelic nature about him and he's
also got a strength while still being
soft enough that he could play the angel
and that's a again a very hard line to
walk those are my two pulses that is
gonna do it for today but i've heard
your comments and you all want more
comic recommendations which means the
world to me so let me give you a few
comic rex for these great x-men i would
start with giant size x-men number one
now when the x-men were founded it was a
team of five they realized around issue
94 they needed more people that's when
nightcrawler storm and a bunch of the
wave of x-men we know and love came in i
would read giant-sized x-men number one
and also check out jim lee's x-men
number one not uncanny x-men number one
x-men number one came out in 1991 that
90s flavor of x-men inspired the tv show
and i also think the 90s x-men is going
to inspire this team we're going to see
on the big screen and then my more
obscure poll is going to be mutant
massacre this was a book that spread
around all of the titles x factor
uncanny x-men x-men it was the first big
crossover event it dealt with the
morlocks the marauders and a lot more
seeds were planted eventually planting
seeds for mr sinister which i do think
they're gonna do in the movies i think
we're eventually gonna get mr sinister i
think we're gonna get omega red and a
lot of characters we haven't seen yet
gotta plant those seeds and it's great
art by john meter junior mutant masker
giant size x-men number one as well as
x-men number one of my three polls that
i think the mcu may pull from you guys
want to see more fan casting if you want
to see me cast chamber banshee monet i
got tons in my head i do think they're
gonna expand out to x factor generation
x x-force all sorts of characters
x-force but if you guys want to see
those fan casting as well you can leave
a comment because greg's like koi you
just cast 12 x-men i don't want to see
or hear any more of this [ __ ] they need
it times two that's 24 fan cast and i
had three for a few characters that's 25
fan cast far too much but if you want to
see it leave a comment below thank you
for being so welcoming to my being part
of the reject nation i appreciate each
and every one of you go read a comic
love your fellow man that's the x-men
are all about because they're better
than the fellow man because they realize
they can help people to get far in life
that's important i love you i'll see you
soon
[Music]